do you think is the key fact that people  think or the misperception that people  have that is most pervasive  that i didn't cross state lines and that  rifle i was carrying was 100 percent  legal for me to carry  dude that is the one that i keep having  to tell people as well i i think you're  right i think that is the number one  thing that is completely uh because i i  saw an article today where they're like  he crossed state lines and carried an  illegal firearm and i think it was  an article that said i was in  self-defense but they said i crossed  state lines and my firearm was illegal  right why does that one bother you more  than the idea of white supremacist is it  why is that the one that sticks in your  cross so much that's the one i hear the  most um that and again on the white  supremacy stuff it's just false right  yeah  so that was the first charge dismissed  too the charge the firearm charge